so Michael Knowles was speaking uh where
was the University of Pittsburgh I
believe pit last night pit last night
when far leftists burned him in effigy
set fires outside obviously in addition
to the Effigy and uh through an
explosive which caused the building to
get locked down and it's it's it's
fairly par for the course we've seen
with far left extremism but uh with all
that happening I'd have to wonder how
would you define burning something with
the intent to intimidate because we have
another story where the guys who marched
in Charlottesville with tiki torches are
being criminally indicted for marching
with tiki torches now look I don't think
anyone in this room likes go like likes
those guys in fact I'm assuming most of
you watching probably don't like those
guys either but they're allowed their
free speech if they want to March around
chanting or whatever okay fine the left
can do it I don't like them but they're
allowed to do it we can clearly see how
the how the government is being
weaponized against certain people and
not against others but I think to put it
um to to condense the thought the left
has weaponized the government against
anyone it doesn't like